talking about things to come for sure
and that could be thunderstorms not
flying machines but things could be
flying around because Gusty winds
lightning comes with all of those we are
looking at some Cloudy Skies this
morning it feels muggy if you haven't
been outside yet when you step Outdoors
you're going to feel it might even feel
it inside if the air conditioning's not
taken taken the mugginess out of the air
for you already 90 degrees in Green
Valley 88 on the Strip we've got mid
80's on the west side so it's warm dew
points are over 60 degrees and we've got
humidity that's up around 40 percent so
a noticeable increase in moisture we
dried out nicely at the end of last week
but we were hot at 112 on Friday
temperatures will be lower today but the
moisture the humidity way up 82 in
Mesquite we've had some rain up around
the Northeast part of the county this
morning and right in that little corner
of Arizona as you go from Clark County
up into Southwest Utah we've had a tenth
of an inch to a third of an inch of rain
76 in kellyanne some rain up in Lincoln
County as well 77 in Indian Springs with
some rain around in mid 80s in Pahrump
where also some very light rain has made
its way into the backside of the spring
mountains showers and thunderstorms
through the middle of the country hot in
the Northeast hot in the Northwest and
wet in the middle of the country with
showers and thunderstorms so the high
pressure is shifted back to the four
corners and that's pushing the monsoon
flow back into our area today you can
see the latest radar shows showers up
around U.S 93 and 95 and there's been a
lot of lightning with these cells as
well you can still see it very active in
Lincoln County we will be looking for
areas that could drop some very heavy
rainfall today with flash flood watches
posted for Northwest Arizona today
through Wednesday and parts of Southern
Utah our local mountains could see some
very heavy rain today could see even
rainfall rates of an inch an hour or
more that's going to lead to some flash
flooding 100 degrees for the valley with
a very good chance of thunderstorms in
some neighborhoods today could be
widespread rain at times but lightning
Gusty winds all of that accompanying
these storms that's a 40 percent chance
today all the way until midnight and a
chance again tomorrow with slight
chances for the rest of the week